a game err I think that it's important
to be a little bit more specific in
terms of what we mean when we're talking
about finance finance is a really big
area there are a lot of people who work
in finance there are lots of different
companies who work in finance and the
interests of every single financial
services firm are not perfectly aligned
nor are the interests of the people
working within a single financial
services firm perfectly aligned nor as
we have discovered with this crisis are
the interests of Management and
shareholders always perfectly aligned so
I think there are lots of very different
interests involved having said that I
think that what we have seen in the past
decade or so is a real growth of the
financial services industry as a
proportion of the economy and I think
with hindsight it's probably fair to say
that it's not that safe and not that
stable for the national economy to have
finance be quite that big I think though
one of the things that it's easy to
forget in the hue and cry over the
crisis is one of the things that did
teach us is how essential financial
services are to the economy with the
reason for that 700 billion dollar
bailout was because the rest of the
economy would not have survived we would
all have gone down with Wall Street so I
think we're in this paradoxical moment
where we've now understood collectively
more than ever how essential financial
services are to the healthy running of
everything else but at the same time I
think there is a daunting understanding
that may be having an economy which is
over-reliant on financial services is
not that terrific and then I do think
that there is another really contentious
issue at the moment which is to what
extent is the collective good served by
really really high profits being made by
financial services firms and by people
working in financial services firms and
I think it's obvious why that should be
such a politically contentious point
right now because taxpayers who in
america are suffering from ten percent
unemployment realize that they rescued
wall street with their money there may
be unemployed or certainly afraid of
becoming unemployed and yet they're
seeing the return of really hefty
salaries and bonuses on wall street so
they're sort of feels like there's a
certain cognitive dissonance there i
think the best way to think about those
questions though is not through the
prism of compensation but through the
prism of what does the system need what
benefits the system overall and also
through the prism of who now benefits
from an implicit or even explicit state
guarantee and i think that we need to be
thoughtful about those firms those parts
of the business which now effectively
have a taxpayer insurance policy because
that's what happened in the fall of 2008
and i think it's quite legitimate and
indeed essential for governments and
regulators to step in and to say okay
you are too big to fail you're lucky in
a way that you were too big to fail
because it meant that we bailed you out
but what that means is in the future we
have to rein in your activities in some
ways to at least minimize the
possibility that this happens again and
and i do think that it's also even as
thoughtful legislators thoughtful
regulators thoughtful economist go
through that sort of a process i think
it's important also to bear in mind that
even in that kind of a more rigorous
analysis you can have players on the
outside who explicitly do not benefit
from a government guarantee and who
therefore
are free to take on the riskiest
possible bets free potentially to make
the greatest possible returns but also
free to go broke and one of the really
interesting stories in this whole crisis
is the dog that didn't bark as it were
which is the hedge fund industry i would
say ahead of the crisis a lot of the
Cassandra voices we're talking about how
hedge funds are posing a huge systemic
risk to the economy to the financial
system and that wasn't a crazy thing to
say and in fact we had seen the example
of ltcm in the 1990s as it turned out
hedge funds did not pose a tremendous
systemic risk and what we saw was a
really healthy operation of market
mechanisms where a lot of hedge funds
went broke a very few made a great deal
of money and industry is now coming back
the question of whether banks should be
allowed to fail or not it really
ultimately has to be about is this Bank
too big or too connected to be allowed
to fail and regulators need to be very
very thoughtful at that moment of crisis
about if we let this institution go will
everybody else suffer or will it just be
the institution that suffers for markets
to function properly we should allow
institutions to fail and we should be
certain that the shareholders and bought
holders and the employees in those
institutions which fail suffer that's
how a market economy works people who
make the right decisions prosper but to
enforce that discipline you have to have
people who make the wrong decisions go
out of business what was really
problematic about this crisis was we
collectively were not in a situation
where that could be allowed to happen
and collectively it became apparent as
the crisis went on and and we do need to
remember that Lehman was allowed to fail
with really painful and instant
implications so at that moment and it
really was a post Lehman moment there
was a belief which I think was right
that you couldn't let the whole system
fail the consequences of that should be
that regulators and lawmakers act now in
this lull after the storm to limit the
number of institutions and the size of
institutions which are too big to fail
and if there is a decision which may be
the case that it's good to have really
big banks that a national economy or
global economy is best served by the
existence of bank universal banks I
think that's a legitimate outcome but
those banks then need to be subject to
much stricter regulation than before so
that it's much less likely that they
should fail
the right outcome is going to be some
sort of a greater move towards
intellectually separating the utility
function of the banking industry from
the casino function and we do need banks
to perform the utility function those
banks should be really really strictly
regulated and very careful thoughtful
policies should be in place about how to
handle the failure of those banks as we
have in the example of the FDIC and the
way it regulates and resolves the
failures of commercial lending banks on
the other side of the divide we should
allow the continued existence of
speculators I don't think speculation is
a dirty word I think speculation is a
really essential part of capitalism but
we need to be sure that speculation the
casino function of Finance exists in a
space where if it fails because
speculation by nature will fail a lot it
doesn't imperil the collective